You may have noticed code snippets using
set large icon for a notification.
Android Wear automatically uses
these as the background image.
However, the android framework only
uses a 64x64 pixel version of the image,
since it is normally shown quite small
in the notification shade on a handheld.
The wearable extender provides
a method called setBackground.
This method can handle high resolution
images, such as mBitmap here, and
send them directly to the wearable so
they'll appear nice and sharp.
However, make sure that the image
you provide is not too large.
If it is too big, you can overwhelm
the memory in the small wearable device.
Instead, we recommend
that you provide 400 x
400 sized images if you
want a static background.
And 640 x 400 if you want to have image
parallax added, where the left and
right edges are used to
simulate background movement.
Make sure that you store these resources
in the drawable-nodpi directory to
insure the framework does
not try to resize them.